Ituturo ko sa iyo ang tungkol sa isang umiikot na bola maliban na hindi ito bola at hindi ito umiikot ngayon sa Qiskit sa
classroom tatalakayin natin ang quantum property na ito na tinatawag na spin sa pamamagitan ng pagtingin sa eksperimento na unang nakahanap ng katibayan para sa
ito maligayang pagdating sa Qiskit in the classroom sa seryeng ito gagamitin natin ang Qiskit upang tuklasin ang ilang pangunahing konsepto na karaniwang
tinatalakay sa mga kursong may kaugnayan sa quantum computing ang bawat video ay sinasamahan din ng isang interactive na module
na naka-link sa paglalarawan sa ibaba kaya siguruhing tingnan iyon ngayon pinag-uusapan natin ang 1922 Stern-Gerlach
eksperimento isa ito sa pinaka-sikat sa kasaysayan ng quantum theory dahil lantarang ipinapakita nito kung paano gumagana ang quantum
spin ngunit hindi iyon ang layunin ni Stern o ni Gerlach ang eksperimento ay dinisenyo upang subukan ang isang bagong quantum model
ng atom na tinatawag na Bohr model na pinangalan kay Niels Bohr na nagmungkahi nito noong 1913 sa modelo ang mga electron ay umikot
sa nucleus sa mga discrete orbital at maaari silang lumipat sa pagitan ng mga orbital na iyon sa pamamagitan ng pagsipsip o pagpapalabas
ng mga photon ang bawat orbital ay may quantized angular momentum na integer multiple ng isang maliit na pundamental na constant
na tinatawag na H noong 1910s at maagang 1920s ang quantum mechanics ay bago pa lamang kaya bago
pa man ito tinatawag na quantum mechanics kaya hindi lahat ay naniniwala sa Bohr model isang pisiko na
nagngangalang Otto Stern ay kinasusuklaman ito tinawag niya ang modelo na kalokohan at nagbanta pa na mag-quit sa physics kung ang Bohr ay
mapatunayang tama si Stern ay determinadong patunayan na mali ang modelo kaya nag-isip siya ng isang matalinong paraan upang subukan ito at
nag-recruit kay Walther Gerlach upang tulungan siyang mag-disenyo at magsagawa ng eksperimento pala hindi niya napatunayan na mali si Bohr natapos
niyang patunayan ang kanyang sariling pagkakamali ang kanilang eksperimento ay napakasimple at ang mga resulta ay napaka-malinaw na halos naitakda na ang
debate ang quantum mechanics ang namamahala sa atomic scale hindi nila ito napansin noon
ngunit ang eksperimento ni Stern at Gerlach ay nakahanap din ng conclusive na katibayan para sa intrinsic spin ng isang electron na isang
bagong pundamental na katangian ng kalikasan na mahalaga upang ipaliwanag ang magnetismo superconductivity at marami sa
chemistry ngayon ipapaliwanag ko sa iyo kung paano gumagana ang eksperimento ni Stern-Gerlach kung ano ang classically na inaasahan nating makita
mula sa eksperimento at kung ano ang nakita ni Stern at Gerlach pagkatapos ipapakita ko sa iyo kung paano mo maaaring patakbuhin ang iyong sariling Stern-
Gerlach na uri ng eksperimento gamit ang Qiskit at isang IBM quantum computer ang pangunahing ideya ng Stern-
Gerlach na eksperimento ay mahanap ang isang paraan upang matukoy kung ang angular momentum ng isang electron sa isang atom ay quantized gaya ng
hula ni Bohr o hindi gaya ng inaasahan ni Stern ginamit nila ang katotohanang ang angular momentum ng electron ay magdudulot din
ng isang maliit na magnetic field sa paligid ng bawat atom kaya maaari mong isipin ang mga ito bilang maliliit na bar
magnets ang eksperimento ay ganito may oven na puno ng pilak na
mga atom at isang magnetic field na may North at South Poles
dito ang field ay mas malakas malapit sa itaas at mas mahina malapit sa ibaba kaya nagdulot ito ng gradient na nakaturo pataas
sa huli may screen sa eksperimento ang oven ay nagpainit sa mga pilak na atom hanggang sa mag-evaporate sila at pagkatapos
lumipad sila palabas ng oven na ang oryentasyon ng maliit na bar magnet ng bawat atom ay ganap na random pagkatapos ang mga atom
ay dumaan sa magnetic field ang mga atom ay itutulak pataas o pababa na may puwersa na nakasalalay sa direksyon ng
North Pole ng bawat atom kaugnay ng field gradient na ito pagkatapos ang mga atom ay tumama sa screen maaaring tingnan ni Stern at Gerlach
kung saan tumama ang mga atom sa screen upang matuto tungkol sa angular momentum ng mga electron inaasahan ni Stern na ang mga atom
sa eksperimento ay kikilos gaya ng paglalarawan ko sa kanila hanggang ngayon tulad ng maliliit na bar magnets na sumusunod sa
mga panuntunan ng classical physics classically ang mga maliliit na atomic magnets na ito ay maaaring nakatuon sa kahit anong random na direksyon kaya habang
naglalakbay sila sa magnetic field maaari silang makaranas ng iba't ibang puwersa na nagtutulak sa kanila pataas o pababa depende sa mga oryentasyong iyon isang magnet
na nakaturo sa parehong direksyon ng gradient ay makakaranas ng malaking puwersa pataas sa kabaligtaran na direksyon
makakaranas ito ng malaking puwersa pababa at kung nasa pagitan ito magiging mas mahinang puwersa kung ang atom ay nakaturo
perpendicular sa gradient wala itong maranasang puwersa at magpapatuloy lamang ito nang tuwid dahil sa
iba't ibang posibleng puwersa ang lahat ng atom ay dapat tumama sa screen sa iba't ibang vertical na puntos ang pattern na gagawin nila
sa screen ay magmumukhang ganito ngunit hindi iyon ang lahat ng nakita ni Stern at
Gerlach sa halip nakita nila ang dalawang ganap na hiwalay na blobs ng mga atom sa screen na walang mga atom sa
gitna wala silang tamang teorya noon upang ipaliwanag ito ngunit ngayon alam natin na nakita nila ito dahil
ang bawat electron ay may ilang halaga ng intrinsic angular momentum sa anyo ng spin na maaari lamang kumuha ng isa
sa dalawang halaga sa ating larawan ng bar magnet nangangahulugan ito na mayroon lamang dalawang pinahintulutang oryentasyon ng atom magnets tinatawag natin
ang dalawang oryentasyong ito na spin up at spin down ang isang qubit sa isang quantum computer
ay katulad ng uri ng spin system na ito at ang ilang quantum computer ay gumagamit ng mga qubit na gawa mula sa electron spin
states kaya maaari tayong magsagawa ng aming sariling eksperimento na Stern-Gerlach gamit ang Qiskit at ang mga qubit sa isang IBM quantum computer
i-map natin ang spin up state ng electron bilang zero state ng qubit at ang spin down state bilang one state
ng qubit nang lumabas ang mga pilak na particle mula sa oven ay may mga randomly oriented na magnetic moments tayo
ay maaaring mag-model ng eksperimento ng Stern-Gerlach sa pamamagitan ng paglikha ng isang simpleng quantum circuit na may isang qubit na nagsisimula sa zero
state kaya ito ay tinatawag na circuit diagram kung saan ang tuktok na wire ay ang qubit at ang mga operasyon na inilapat sa qubit
ay lumabas bilang mga kahon sa wire ang mga kahon na RX at RZ ay mga quantum gate na
epektibong inikot ang magnetic orientation ng atom maaari tayong pumili ng random na Theta at F values dito upang iikot ang
qubit ng isang random na halaga ginagaya nito ang oven na nagluluwal ng mga atom na may random na spin orientations ang gray na kahon ay
ang ating sukat sinasabi nito sa atin kung ang qubit ay nasa state zero o isa at ipinapadala ang sukat na iyon sa isang classical bit ang
double line na may label na C ang bahaging ito ay katumbas ng pagsukat kung ang atom ay nasa spin up o spin down sa pamamagitan ng pagtingin sa
kung saang punto ito tumama sa screen maaari tayong gumamit ng Qiskit primitive na tinatawag na sampler upang patakbuhin ang eksperimento nang maraming beses na bawat isa ay may
iba't ibang random na halaga para sa Theta at f pagkatapos ng 100 samples makakakuha tayo ng measurement histogram na magmumukhang ganito mga
50% ng oras ang qubit ay nasusukat bilang zero at 50% ng oras nasa state 1 ito ito ang parehong resulta na nakita ni Stern
at Gerlach lagi itong spin up o spin down ngunit hindi kailanman sa pagitan sa puntong ito maaaring mag-isip ka na
siyempre nakakuha tayo ng dalawang discrete na resulta nagsagawa tayo ng eksperimento sa isang digital quantum computer na nagbabalik lamang ng
zero o isa at ito ay totoo ngunit tandaan na ang buong dahilan kung bakit nagbabalik ng binary na resulta ang mga quantum computer at ang katotohanan
na gumagana ang quantum computing ay dahil mismo sa quantization ng spin na unang natuklasan ni Stern at Gerlach
ang mga qubit sa IBM quantum computers ay hindi batay sa mga spin ngunit maraming iba pang quantum computers ang ganoon kaya ang pagsasagawa ng isang
eksperimento ng Stern-Gerlach sa isang quantum computer ay nagbibigay-daan sa atin na muling tuklasin ang spin quantization
mula noong 1922 nagsagawa na ng napakaraming extension sa orihinal na eksperimento ng Stern-Gerlach ang mga extension na ito ay kinabibilangan ng
pagpapadala ng parehong beam ng mga atom sa pamamagitan ng maraming Stern-Gerlach apparatus upang makita kung paano kumikilos ang mga spin sa iba't ibang
sitwasyon narito ang isa ipadala natin ang mga atom sa pamamagitan ng isang apparatus upang paghiwalayin ang beam sa dalawa na katumbas ng isang
spin up beam at isang spin down beam at pagkatapos ipadala ang bawat isa sa mga beam na iyon sa pamamagitan ng kanilang sariling hiwalay
na apparatus gamit ang Qiskit ang quantum circuit na katumbas ng eksperimentong ito ay katulad ng huling isa ngunit may dalawa
na sukat sa halip ng isa dito pinapalitan natin ang mga random na rotasyon na gumaya ng epekto ng oven ng isang
gate na tinatawag na Hadamard dahil ang pag-apply ng Hadamard ay magbibigay sa atin ng parehong mga probability ng sukat gaya ng oven
ngunit mas simple itong gamitin kaya sinusukat natin nang isang beses at pagkatapos nang dalawang beses at ang
resultang measurement histogram para sa eksperimento ay nagmumukhang ganito kung saan ang mga bit string sa X axis ay katumbas ng
mga kinalabasan ng dalawang sukat kung ang qubit ay nasukat na zero sa parehong pagkakataon iyon ay katumbas ng 0 0 bit string o kung
ang una ay nasukat na zero pagkatapos ay isa iyon ay katumbas ng one zero at iba pa mukhang kung nasukat ito bilang spin up sa
unang eksperimento magiging spin up ito sa ikalawa gayundin sa mga spin down na atom nangangahulugan ito na sa unang eksperimento
ay pantay ang probability ng pagsukat ng pataas o pababa ngunit sa ikalawang eksperimento ang kinalabasan ay natukoy na kaya ang
dalawang screen sa dulo ng bawat isa sa ikalawang Stern-Gerlach apparatus ay magkakaroon lamang ng isang tuldok ang isang screen ay magkakaroon ng
lahat ng spin up na atom at ang isa ay magkakaroon ng lahat ng spin down na atom para sa ating susunod na eksperimento
magsimula tayo ng isang beam ng purong spin up na atom sa isang aktwal na pisikal na eksperimento ng Stern-Gerlach magagawa mo ito sa pamamagitan ng pagpapadala
ng mga ito sa pamamagitan ng isang Stern-Gerlach apparatus at pagharang ng beam na naitulak pababa kaya lahat ng atom na naitulak pataas ay
spin up ngayon ipadala natin ang beam na ito sa pamamagitan ng isa pang Stern-Gerlach apparatus ngunit sa pagkakataong ito i-rotate natin ang mga magnet ng 90° upang
ang field gradient ay mag-deflect ng mga atom na naglalakbay sa ganitong paraan sa kaliwa o sa kanan sa halip makikita ba natin
ang isang tuldok o dalawa o isang bagay na ganap na naiiba para sa eksperimentong ito
patakbuhin natin ang sumusunod na circuit sa Qiskit magsisimula tayo sa zero state dahil ang ating beam ng mga atom sa eksperimentong ito ay lahat
spin up pagkatapos ang Hadamard gate na ito ay nagpapalitan ng mga x at z coordinates upang magkaroon ng epekto ng pag-rotate ng
Stern-Gerlach apparatus kaya ngayon sinusukat na natin ang spin projection kaliwa o kanan sa halip na pataas o pababa dito makukuha natin
ang measurement histogram na nagmumukhang ganito kaya makikita natin na ang spin sa kahabaan ng X ay maaari lamang ding kumuha ng dalawang halaga
na maaari nating tawaging spin left at spin right kaya ang eksperimentong ito ay nagpapakita na kung susukat ka ng X projection ng isang spin
na dati ay nasukat na spin up sa kahabaan ng Z magiging spin left o right ito na may pantay na probability i-contrast natin ang
ito sa huling pagkakataon sa classical na inaasahan upang talagang maipakita ang pagkakaiba classically tandaan na
sinabi ko na kung ang maliit na atomic bar magnet ay nakaturo perpendicular sa magnetic field gradient ng apparatus
ang puwersa sa atom na iyon ay dapat na zero hindi ito dapat na naitulak pataas o pababa sa kasong iyon nakikita lamang natin ang isang tuldok sa
gitna ng screen sa halip nakikita natin ang dalawang tuldok kaya kalahati ng mga atom ay may spin left at kalahati ay may spin right kahit
na dati silang nasukat bilang pataas kaya mula sa isang quantum mechanical na perspektibo habang maaaring matukso tayong
ituring na ang spin up ay isang vector na nakaturo pataas at ang spin down ay isa na nakaturo pababa hindi ito kasingsinple nito gaya ng makikita natin
mula sa huling eksperimento upang talaga maunawaan ang nangyayari dito kailangan nating mas malalim na tuklasin ang mga paksa ng
quantum superposition at sukat na magiging video para sa isa pang araw tulad ng naiwan tayong may mas maraming
tanong tungkol sa kung paano eksaktong gumagana ang quantum mechanics gayundin si Stern at Gerlach ang kanilang eksperimento ay hindi naipliwanag
ang lahat ngunit nakatulong ito nang malaki sa pagtatatag ng quantum mechanics bilang mahalaga sa pag-unawa sa natural
na mundo isa ito sa pinakamahalagang pundamental na eksperimento sa quantum mechanics na kapwa nagpatunay ng quantization
ng momentum at nagbigay ng katibayan para sa isang bagong pundamental na katangian ng kalikasan na tinatawag na spin upang tunay na makipaglaban at
maunawaan ang mga panuntunan ng quantum world ang mga pisiko tulad ni Stern at Gerlach ay kailangang magsumikap sa pagdidisenyo
ng mga eksperimento paggawa ng mga hula at kung minsan ay maling tama talagang walang kapalit sa pagtry ng mga bagay-bagay d'yan mismo
kaya kung gusto mong subukan ang pagpapatakbo ng ilang tunay na quantum experiments pumunta sa Stern-Gerlach module
na naka-link sa paglalarawan salamat sa panonood at hanggang sa muli